[Music]
okay everyone I'm so excited I'm with
the man himself Jeffrey Dean Morgan
Jeffrey because this show takes place in
New York have you been pushing for
season two to get closer Upstate so you
can film near the farm
yeah let's go back to the woods but in
New York actually that's not a bad idea
I would love to go upstate but I have a
I have an apartment and we we have an
apartment in the city as well so it
worked out for me either way and as long
as I can see my family on weekends I'm
cool uh the last couple years had been
rough without the family so I was ready
to get to New York and and it was great
to shoot here hell yeah and what I also
love about you is that you are a huge
Seahawks fan and a big football fan in
general so when I see you tweeting about
the Seahawks I think we all want to know
are you one of us meeting like are you
got Red Zone on are you chilling
football all day oh yeah oh football all
day because I do fantasy as well uh so I
I have to check everybody when the
Seahawk game's on that's what I'm
focused on but otherwise I'm checking my
fantasy team and see what's happening
there I'm on a fantasy league with
Walking Dead crew in fact that will
never go away we started it probably six
years ago
and it will that that that League will
continue well past this show and any
other spin-offs so standard of PPR
standard lot yes thank you everyone it's
Jeopardy Morgan check out dead City it's
amazing thank you so much man
thank you